good morning everyone my name is
researcher Miller and the SCP were going
to be looking at today is SCP 207 object
class safe special containment
procedures SCP 207 is to be stored in a
waterproof flocking metal container
measuring 1 by 0.5 by 0.5 meter the key
is to be issued to the current head
researcher of site bio containment area
SCP 207 is to be retained inside this
area at all times and all personnel
entering the area should be checked for
any food or drink items in addition to
any other searches required any staff
seat ingesting SCP 207 - 1 are to be
retained for future study with all
foundation clearance levels removed all
vending machines in site are only to
dispense clear carbonated beverages any
variation from transparent is to be
investigated immediately description as
CP 207 refers to a crate containing 24
coca-cola brand cola drinks the bottles
are designated SCP 207 a through 2x SCP
207 B is currently the active bottle for
testing no other bottles are to be
opened without authorization from 2
level for researchers all bottles have
been clearly labeled to aid
identification the liquid held inside
these has been confirmed to be identical
across all of SCP 207 and should not be
ingested outside of supervise testing
the liquid has been classified as SCP
207 1 and is to be treated as a class 2
chemical hazard SCP 207 - 1 does not
appear to alter with age however the act
of testing Bonnell should have its
protective cover kept on outside of
removing liquid for testing
a spectroscopy and chemical tests have
shown higher than usual concentrations
of caffeine and sugars both natural and
artificial along with the practical
effect of this is when a subject drinks
SCP 2 and 7-1 they will effectively no
longer require sleep or rest nor attempt
to sleep or rest this effect is not
lessened by any soporific or medication
yet tested on test subjects however only
a quantity larger than 5 milliliters
will cause this effect the reason for
this boundary existing has not been
found although it is hypothesized by
doctor that as such unless authorized by
2 level 3 researchers only 5 milliliters
of SCP 207 - 1 is to be used for testing
amounts higher than this have shown no
difference in effect with the exception
of the subject SCP 207 was recovered
from see addendum in addition to
removing the need for rest SCP 207 - 1
also causes an increase in motor
reaction and psychological functions the
increase is linear in progression with
an estimated 50% increase measured by
standard medical protocols plus or minus
5% every six hours the practical
application of ingestion is that the
subject is able to think react and move
faster than others who have not ingested
SCP 207 - one mental proficiencies show
the IQ of the subject to rise in line
with other increases however SCP 207 -
one does not alter the body of affected
subjects physiology remains unchanged
and as such can rarely support the
increase in activity no subjects have
lasted longer than 48 hours during
testing with the cause of death varying
from massive and
lorig and failure to exsanguination due
to major artery ruptures subjects also
begin to show stress after roughly 24
hours usually making each movement
extremely carefully in order to avoid
accidents tests SCP 207 alpha and Rho
have shown that after approximately 24
hours the increase is caused by a CP 207
- 1 means subjects can easily
underestimate their speed most
specifically in tests SCP 207 ro the
subject was able to escape the
containment area despite a 5 metre wall
however this caused the subjects
internal bone structure - addendum SCP
207 was recovered from college after
reports of student moving from failing
grades in all areas including physical
sports - top percentile marks and
record-breaking performances in physical
areas agent embedded in the local police
force brought in for interview subject
revealed the existence of SCP 207 during
the interview
however escape attempt while class-a
amnesiacs were being administered
resulted in the subject violently
cause of death organ failure due to
massive internal hemorrhage as SCP 207 a
was empty on recovery it is believed
ingesting a full bottle SCP 207
recovered from subjects home asap 207 a
already empty reported to local police
force as missing pursue no further cause
for surveillance college at this time
okay this was a short lecture today but
I'm gonna stop here thank you all for
listening and you were all dismissed
goodbye
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Andre Bessette Desmond Hoskins and
Gansu Barry thank you all very much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos and some other cool
stuff as well go to patreon.com/scishow
[Music]
you